state of georgia has been pretty good to
our friend stacy abrams not clear what
abrams does for a living and yet somehow
she has been able to afford two homes in
the state of georgia but she's not
grateful for it over the weekend abrams
who was apparently running for office
again despite being the real governor of
georgia
went out of her way to attack
the state she hopes to lead watch
i am tired of hearing about being the
best state in the country to do business
when we are the worst state in the
country to live
well there's a campaign tactic you don't
see very often i hate this place elect
me
robert patillo it's a radio talk show
host in atlanta he's a statewide
democratic party strategist and regional
director for the rainbow push coalition
he joins us tonight robert thanks so
much for coming on so um you don't often
hear people seeking to lead a state
attack the state what do you think that
was about
well i think it was a gaffe it's a faux
pas this is what happens often when you
have a campaign where most of your
fundraisers are coming out of california
most of your talking points and
political strategists are coming out of
new york and dc and the same things that
work in d.c aren't going to work in
dakula georgia you have to get out there
and actually talk to people in the
grassroots you have to talk to some of
the political strategists and political
uh consultants who are right here in the
state and there you have people like d
dawkins hageler who's running for
secretary of state who's been to all 159
counties and talks to people on a daily
basis you have to dig down and make sure
that you are reflecting the views of the
people of your state not simply people
who are putting money into the campaign
well that seems like a theme here so if
you look at the polling on what voters
care about surprise surprise it's not
global warming it's not ukraine
it's inflation gas prices in the economy
those are the top three so if your
campaign is really run out of the west
side of los angeles how can you be in
touch with those issues i wonder
well i think a big part of it is going
to have to be going on a listening tour
around the state making sure you're
talking to people in small diners and
local communities and i'm from down in
harris county georgia so we we view
things a little bit differently we see
people from atlanta being outsiders
alone people from outside the state or
outside the region so i think you have
to start working some of those regional
people people like keith mccants and
middle georgia scout smith who's a great
political consultant there in the state
john jackson who's a veteran who can
connect you to those communities when
you start actually listening to the
voters instead of listening to the
consultants that's when you're able to
win a race and particularly we have a
fractured republican party like we have
in the state of georgia right now right
we have david perdue attacking brian
kemp for not being republican enough i
think that you have an opportunity to
really build that grassroots support
while they're having a civil war on the
other side
yeah i mean that it seems like you
couldn't run a party worse than the
state of georgia's run its republican
party so
robert i appreciate your thoughts on
that thank you very much
thanks anytime
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight